good afternoon everyone
my name is rachel hardigan and i'm a
senior writer with national geographic
today we're continuing our conversation
our celebration of women's suffrage
and talking about the ongoing fight for
political representation
it took more than 70 years for such
suffragists to get the vote for women
but even after the 19th amendment passed
state and federal laws still made it
difficult if not impossible for women of
not
non-white women to vote 100 years later
equal political representation
still hasn't been achieved but we have
people here who are working on it
i'm thrilled to be here with two women
who are continuing the centuries-long
tradition of women fighting for equal
rights
nicole montclair donaghy is the
executive director of north dakota
native vote
she's coming to us from bismarck north
dakota
and igen pooh is the director of the
national domestic workers alliance
co-director of caring across
generations and co-founder of super
majority and she
is joining us from chicago thank you to
both of you for being here
so let's jump right in among the women
who couldn't vote when the 19th
amendment
passed were native people who weren't
acknowledged as citizens
until 1924 and native communities now
still face barriers to voting
so nicole can you tell us about the work
of north dakota native vote
sure so uh thank you for having me my
um so north dakota native vote was
began in 2018 in response to the voter
identification law that was
um that was upheld by the supreme court
by that
in that same year that required all
north dakotans to have a physical
address
on their identification cards and so
that limited a lot of people from even
trying to get a ballot because on
reservations we don't have
uh traditional street addresses all of
our mail comes by post office and so
that's how north dakota native came into
being
since then we've created a full
year-round organization that is working
on
enhancing native leadership building
power for our tribal communities and
getting people involved in community
organizing so that they are at the table
when decisions are made for our people
thank you nicole and you know also
looking back women labor activists were
crucial to pushing women's suffrage over
the finish line
hi jen can you talk about how the three
organizations that you
work with sort of form a similar
intersection of labor activism
and political representation
sure thank you for having me and it's
really an honor
to be in conversation with you and
nicole
so at the the national domestic workers
alliance is
an organization that represents the
millions of women
mostly women of color who work in our
homes
providing caregiving and cleaning
services and
it's incredibly vital work and
it's the work that makes everything else
possible right
makes it possible for us to do what we
do
knowing that some of the most important
parts of our lives our most important
people
in our lives are in really good hands
and yet it's some of the most
undervalued and invisible work in our
economy
today and there's a long history behind
that and the national domestic workers
alliance
is a growing community of domestic
workers that's trying to change that
to bring dignity and respect to the work
and to make
domestic work jobs and all care jobs
really good jobs
that you can take pride in support your
family on
and see real opportunity
and caring across generations is a
coalition that we started in 2011
to really bring together all the people
who need care
older people people with disabilities
family caregivers
together with the caregiving workforce
to
put forward a new vision for the care
economy
that would not only allow for
wider universal access to the care that
we need to take care of our families
but ensure that all the jobs in the care
economy are really good jobs
and as a sister organization to that
family of groups
we also there's also an organization
called care in action
which is a 501c4 organization that's
focused on
building political power and
representation for women of color
especially women of color working in
low-wage service jobs like domestic work
and super majority you do a lot
i have a lot of homes and super majority
is a new new-ish organization
that was launched to
capture and project the power of the
supermajority of women in this country
who power everything and yet are
still underrepresented and
we hope to build the largest
program woman to woman voter
mobilization program
in history um to to participate
in this election wow
so our conversation is sort of based on
the assumption
that representation is a good thing and
that seems kind of obvious
but can you both talk about
why representation is important
in general and maybe specifically in the
communities that you're working with
i don't know who wants to start i didn't
answer
i can i can kick it off by saying
one that whether it's in our democracy
or in our economy
you cannot value what you cannot see
and um and for us
representation is not just about what we
see
but what that makes possible what
representation
from our communities makes possible
in politics but also in policy
right so having the ability for young
girls of color
to see uh women running for
every office up and down the ballot and
to know that they could
be the president of the united states or
a vice president
is is really transformative because it
it does
open up the realm of what's possible
right
that that visibility is not just about
that visibility it's about the realm
of what's possible and in policy it's
the same thing
it's what representation from the
experiences of our communities
mean when you're trying to solve
problems when you're trying to create
policy when you're trying to change
systems to be able to do it from the
vantage point
of some of the least visible and most
vulnerable communities in the country
is actually essential to creating policy
solutions
that lift everyone where no one is left
behind and so i just think it's not just
about
who we see but it's about what that
means
in our politics in our families in our
communities in our sense of self
and also from a policy standpoint
policies can't be developed if you don't
know that they're about the people that
they're
supposed to be serving helping what
about you nicole what do you why do you
think representation is so important
yes so like you said earlier rachel
native american people have not been
able to vote until 1924
in in best cases and so we've been on
we've been on what we call turtle island
for since time immemorial and we are
just now
at a point where other communities are
realizing that
we also need to be represented native
american people have been here forever
we need to have that representation and
we need to be at the table when these
decisions are made or
at least being involved when when there
are decisions being made and so like
um tribal nations when you live on a
reservation you have to deal with five
different forms of government you have
to deal with state
city county federal and tribal and so
we should always be aware of what's
happening to us and we should always
have
the opportunity to use our voice and and
so
um working in in
in the work that i that we do i i've
also
uh worked in oil and gas communities
where decisions were being made where
people
don't you know didn't know that these
decisions were being made yet
the pollution and all of the um
externalizing of operations was was
impacting the land and water and the air
that they breathed and so
i i think that it is representation is
important at all levels from
nonpartisan seats like school boards all
the way up into
to the governor you know we we need to
have that voice
so does it make a big difference in 2018
that
finally two native american women were
elected to congress
that is an amazing beat and i am they
are inspirations to me sharice david
and deborah holland and it also goes to
show that that there's more native
american women coming there's more
native there's more of us coming there's
more of us on our way
and one great case in our state is uh
ruth anna buffalo who
is the first democratic house of
representatives
um sits in the north dakota house of
representatives she
ran a true grassroots campaign and
knocked down doors and walked
you know logged hundreds of miles by i
guess getting her voice out there it
takes a lot of work and we just didn't
fall from the sky
there's so many women that have laid
that path before us and ruth and
deb and charisse are those ladies that
are making those trails
yeah can i just add something to that
sure
so first of all i'm waiting for nicole
to run for office
second of all um just i just want to
shout out congresswoman deb holland for
a minute because i was just on a zoom
with her yesterday
about caregiving and she's not only
representing the interests of native
people
in congress and her own constituents but
she's representing the interests of
millions tens of millions of caregivers
who have no
voice in our politics or in our policy
and she has been championing
laws and resolutions and initiatives
that lift up family caregivers lift up
professional caregivers
and she talks about her own personal
experience where
she was not able to afford child care
and so she had to both
figure out how she was going to work and
earn a living and income and support her
family
and take care of her own kids as her
parents got more frail she was a family
caregiver
she talks about those direct experiences
and those direct experiences
translate into policy and so i think
sometimes when we think about
representation from just an identity
lens
we think about right that that's
actually quite important
it's also about the values and the
experiences that get reflected
whether they have to do with race
specifically or not
i just think we have so much brilliance
to nicole's point
and talent that has been suppressed
by a political system and process that
is
unjust and unequal and if we actually uh
removed some of those obstacles and had
a really reflective democracy
there would be so much creativity and
brilliance
that would be in unleashed to solve the
very challenging problems that we face
as a nation
my friend franklin leonard who runs the
blacklist always talks about the film
hidden figures i don't know if you
saw that film oh yeah but what he says
about it which i thought was so wise is
the thing that it really the big
takeaway there is that
if those women given all the barriers
that they faced as black women
were still able to take us to the moon
imagine if those barriers didn't exist
would we all be flying around in jet
packs or
right like solar-powered jetpacks you
know i think it's just
it's just a reminder that we are all
harmed by the barriers that exist
to native communities black communities
immigrant communities from
full and complete political
participation and power in our democracy
yeah that i mean that reminds me i mean
one thing that struck me
um about the suffrages is
they were sort of building power from
not much you know they didn't have much
access to power and one thing
i jen that you said to me i spoke to you
i think right when everything was
shutting down in march you talked about
how you had to think about building
power
for people who don't have it like how do
you
create something out of nothing but it's
not really nothing
but how do you do it it's only nothing
in the context of
a system erases and invisibilizes people
and and what we have to do is we have to
invent and imagine a new
new systems and new cultures and new
ways of being and i think both nicole's
work and our
our work in the in the domestic workers
movement has been about how do we create
new frameworks that see and value
people who have been undervalued and
invisibilized
in our culture and our politics and once
we start to do that and we do it
collectively
it's transformative we call it building
power from the margins until the margins
disappear
right it's like we our ideas they start
in the shadows because they have to
because of the kinds of
disenfranchisement that we've been
subjected to
but those ideas in the end are the ideas
of the future
and um and i think that that's what
we're seeing now with a lot of the work
of people who've been trying to build
power from places of very little power
and access
that's the innovation that's the future
and that's how we get to the kind of
multi-racial democracy that we deserve
and that is actually possible in this
country
yeah um
one thing in a previous one of our
previous events
the historian martha jones was talking
about voting
and she was talking about i mean that's
a form of power obviously and it might
not seem like much but
one vote at a time is a form of power
and she's talked about the tactical
importance of voting but she also talked
about the symbolic
importance of voting and i wonder nicole
if you could talk a little bit about
that symbolic importance of both you
know having this law
passed in north dakota that made it
harder for native north dakotans to vote
but then getting people to do like what
did that what does that mean to people
to be able to vote
well so with our in our communities and
in native american communities i mean
we've always
had pride in this land we've always
protected this land and and having that
ability to vote on these lands and
decide who's in power is is a big deal
for us
um a lot of our communities like i said
earlier are not able to speak for it for
ourselves when it comes to decision
making
and too often like we get left out and
people don't think that we're here
anymore and so
um taking that step to make sure that
our communities have the right to vote
is
is is monumental for our communities
that are on the margin
and um having having people understand
that their right
to vote is is huge especially in indian
country i've heard statistics at one
point in 2018
where it said that the native vote was
five more times powerful than off
reservations because we
are we are not able to vote and as as
easy easily and conveniently as people
off the reservation and so
it's it's something that we are um
we are educating our people with that
this
this right to vote has been ours since
1924 but it's not always an easy task
for us and so always remembering that
and the um the symbolic meaning behind
it of
just having that voice and standing your
ground on this land where we
where we were where we always have been
yeah what about you i generally what
about the
the people you're working with who are
and
totally correct me if i'm wrong but i it
seems hard to
sort of build up a movement with people
who are you know one person is working
in one house you know their people are
sort of separated how do you
build up this movement and then what
does
participating in the political process
mean to people who may be somewhat
isolated
yeah it's always the people with the
least amount of power who understand
just how important power is and
um and i'll tell you a story of
our our democracy has so many
hidden shiros and heroes
and i consider nicole one of them
and another one for me is a woman named
dorothy bolden
who was the who was a domestic worker in
atlanta georgia in the 1950s and 60s and
as the civil rights movement was
building momentum
she was actually a neighbor of martin
luther king juniors
and she went and knocked on his door and
she said
i want to be a part of this movement i
want in and
he said to her great organize the
domestic workers
and she did she formed the national
domestic workers union
which ended up organizing thousands of
black domestic workers throughout the
south and
winning pay raises and a lot of progress
in that time and the only requirements
and she's our
she's our kind of movement mother she's
our ancestors who we have built upon
but the only requirements to join the
national domestic workers union were
that one you were a domestic worker and
two
you were registered to vote and for her
the right to vote and the ability to be
empowered
in your job were fundamentally connected
and i do think that we have lost the
connection
between having power in the economy and
having power in our democracy
and it's actually fundamentally
connected
it is not an accident that our unequal
system
just keeps becoming unequal because the
concentration of power and wealth is
just increasing
at the very very top and
and and that is political power that's
being concentrated in the service of
economic power right
and so what we have to do to democratize
our economy and our politics
is to really remember the integration of
those two things
and to figure out how we put more power
in the hands of
everyday people in the ballot box
at the ballot box in the workplace in
the community
that's what has to happen for real
change to happen in this country
well can you talk about super majority
then i mean
underrepresentation doesn't necessarily
mean that
your numbers are a minority women are a
majority
but not i'm not articulating this very
well but
a majority in numbers may be a minority
in power what do you hope super majority
will do
i mean the whole point is to change that
yeah you know i think we power
everything
as women i mean growing up being raised
by my mom and my grandmother
i literally thought they walked on water
they did everything
they they powered everything in our home
and in our community and they went to
work and they
and um and then as i grew older
i realized the disconnect between
the fact that they do all the work and
power everything but they don't actually
make all the decisions right and they
don't actually
have the power to make all the decisions
and that i just saw
how much of a disconnect there was
between the role of women
in everything and the actual amount of
power and decision making that we have
as women and i think super majority is
really trying to bridge that gap
where we sh we are more than half the
workforce
half the electorate right we're so many
things
and we've never aggregated our power
to say that the women's agenda is the
agenda
right um that women's issues is
everyone's issues
it's everyone's issues i mean the fact
that we're the majority of everything
and yet
we're still treated as a special
interest group
is one of the most absurd narrative
and cultural kind of jedi mind tricks
that i've
and so i just think we have um
we have this moment where i think women
are on fire and awakening
to that contradiction in new ways every
single day
and you know it's just and i think women
like representative holland are
just breaking the doors open for so many
of us
this year there are more black women
running for united states congress than
ever in history and this is how we're
going to do it we're going to show up at
the polls
at un unprecedented numbers and we're
going to keep just
opening those doors and changing those
systems
yeah nicole at one point um
i think when we spoke in the spring you
talked about
how uh
you are part of a matriarchal society
and most of the work being done at the
grassroots level is being done by women
i wonder if you could talk a little bit
about how that plays out
in the community on the ground in your
work
how do the women take charge yeah so
historically
i mean our at least in our lakota and
our lakota culture women we're decision
makers we were a matriarchal society
we still are and that has been brought
forward
through all like the centuries women are
the nurturers women are the backbone of
the nation
and there's this old saying um
that my ancestors used to say is that
men did the dangerous work but women did
the impossible
and so like that
so women women have always had this role
at least in our culture um to make
decisions but
in in more contemporary times it is
women that is leading the way because we
we see the need we we we have that
nurturing heart and we have the
we have that intuit that intuition and
the strength to carry these movements
and i'm not saying that there's no men
that are in there but it
but mostly it is women that is that is
taking the charge here
and i i really don't know
why that is i mean maybe it's because
our our communities have adopted
westernized
society this westernized westernized
forms of government where
you know women are still subjugated on
some sense but
but it is the women that have been
leading a lot of these movements at
least in my
my region cole can you say the quote one
more time
men do the dangerous work but women do
the impossible
okay you need to make a t-shirt
yes of that quote and have
all the money raised go to your
organization
that's a great idea i still say we do a
lot of dangerous work too though so
yeah impossible and dangerous that could
be the like
yeah i like that so
now you nicole you've put in so many
miles on your car
north dakota is a big state the
reservations are spread out all over the
place
can you talk a little bit about just
what you're doing as you're going from
place to place what
like how you do what you do oh man i
i pray a lot
so in 2018 i was one of two field
organizers on the ground
for north dakota i need to vote myself
in prairie seminole
but we were covering a huge state and
all of our reservations are widely
spread out and
of course across rural regions and so
i i would sometimes take people with me
like my daughter my daughter is
a natural-born organizer she's 15 years
old now and she would come and help with
with the work that we're doing um or i
would
listen to stories from you know i love
audiobooks and listening
to like our our oral oral histories is
also something that's kept me
kept me going but just being in in that
energy
and being a part of the change in the
movement that's happening in north
dakota
it makes me it makes my heart so full
and it makes me
so proud to be a part of this these
movements and
leading from behind and so um
i'm i'm not one for the spotlight and i
always
get a little you know
a little shy about things but i i really
want
i i have that love for my people so that
i really want to be that resource and
and do
give them the things that they need so
that they can we
we all can rise together
and are people receptive i mean do you
ever
do either of you ever run into people
who
say well the system is not welcoming to
us and why should i participate in the
system that doesn't want me to
be participating yes uh that does happen
a lot
especially in in our on our reservations
people are like why
you know my vote doesn't matter why
should i vote why should i be counted in
census why should i get involved you
know
but they i always tell them any place
that these decisions are being made
you are more welcome there you need to
be there you belong there you know
this part these are public processes and
we need to be a part of it otherwise
we'll be left behind and so we have to
just give our communities that education
and
that empowerment to to move forward
i think that's one of the reasons why
our organizations are so important here
and
i think more than any other election in
history
this is the election where what's on the
ballot is not the candidates what's on
the ballot is whether it's actually
worth it to vote
and and of course it is worth it
but i think that with in the middle of a
pandemic
with so much misinformation and
disinformation and voter suppression
there is there's um there is a very
concerted
effort to suppress the vote and so
we have a real uphill battle here to
really remind people
that democracies don't work if we don't
participate
they just won't there's there's no
chance
that it will work without us and so
everything that they care about
everything that they're worried about
everything that's maybe keeping them
from actually prioritizing voting like
caring for their children or going to
work where they're underpaid or
not having health care that's all on the
ballot
and we have to remind people
and encourage people and help people
navigate
the really complex environment that has
been created by
um by our current
context well that um
leads to a question from our audience um
so what gives you the most hope in this
current moment
that was hopefully do you hope that we
will continue making progress
um this is going to sound kind of weird
but the thing that actually gives me
hope is that
people who are trying to suppress the
vote and rig the system
and and keep people
out of our democracy they have to try to
change the rules
because they know that the majority of
the people
in this country want
freedom justice inclusion equity caring
that
in this country in the end the
majoritarian values are towards
empathy compassion and inclusion and
they have to change the rules to
suppress us
and so it actually is a reminder that we
have the power we need
to make this the country of our dreams
and that gives me a lot of hope like
that like
listen you know you are not alone in
your frustration
we are a majority and if we do our jobs
right we can
we can we can shape the future
fundamentally and um and i know
so many organizers so many domestic
workers so many
women of color who are doing the hard
work
that nicole is doing because they
believe that too
and that is an inspiration to me
and i know that you know even just in
the primaries that we've seen so far
where there's been a lot of voter
suppression people are standing in line
for hours upon hours to realize their
right to vote
and in the middle of a pandemic and that
is inspiring to me
right that is what's going to protect
and preserve and improve our democracy
what about you nicole is there anything
that's giving you hope
well i you know i i have to
i mean like being an organizer i i
always fall back on like
our axioms for organizers where you
organize like hell for the living
you know there's i have to have that
type of mentality but then
deep down i'm just a mom you know that
just wants
a better world for my kids and
um in our culture we plan ahead for
seven generations and we
we want to have that a better place for
the future generations and so that's
what gives me
a lot of my hope and and being in
company of so many powerful women
there i have mentors that i looked up to
and that
are right in right in the throes with us
you know doing the same type of work
trying to trying to build um equity
trying to build power for our
communities that's what gives me a lot
of hope is knowing that there's so many
people that
are are doing this work and i'm not
alone doing it
are you working to also kind of
raise up people like your daughter or
younger people um to build up more
leaders in the community too
yes we we are our uh
our slogan at our organization north
dakota nato vote is inspiring
in or to inspire indigenous action and
you know my daughter is one of many
empowered young women that are on the
rise and so i'm i'm just
yeah there's more of us coming that's
what
what about you igen are you now the
domestic
workers organization you're also sort of
training up leaders too isn't that part
of what you do
yeah absolutely yeah we have
um thousands of domestic worker leaders
all over the country
who are trying to pass bills in state
legislatures and
trying to win ppe for caregivers and
cities and
um and it's been
um it's been a really interesting time
to see so much leadership grow
in the midst of so many attacks on women
of color
on immigrants on so many people who
don't have very much power and to see
the incredible resilience
and determination has been the thing
that's really carried me through the
pandemic is just
how much leadership there is among women
and women of color
and working class people who
really just want to be able to live with
dignity
i mean everybody's fighting right now
and um
and it's a multi-generational movement
that's building
um and i think it has to be like our and
one of the beautiful things i've learned
from native leaders has been this
intergenerational connection and the
fact that
the fact that in dominant american
culture we're so siloed
by generations and that there often
breaks
within our movements across generations
it just means that we end up making the
same mistakes
over and over again and mistakes are
inevitable we're going to make
mistakes i just want to make new ones
but i want our kids to make new ones
right
and to be able to build off of hard
learned lessons
from one generation to the next so yes
we think a lot about intergenerational
experience and support and
leadership and and i think it's really
crucial
the pandemic raises a lot of issues i
think
in 1918 with the flu that actually
in some ways sort of helped the
suffragists because all the men were at
world war
you know fighting world war one the
women had to step
up and sort of prove that they could be
the nurses that they could do all these
things and
and you know they sort of earned some
credit that way i wonder
how much effect the pandemic
will have i mean there's it'll have a
kaleidoscope of effects
obviously but how do you think it's
going to affect
political representation
but he wants to take that well
um one thing is that i i do
i feel this is one reason why i feel
hopeful is that
the pandemic has revealed so many
inequities and um
and fragilities and
um that we just
have needed to address for a very very
long time
and the fact that we are now really
honoring
our essential workers who've been
invisible working in low-wage jobs as
farm workers as home care workers
as grocery workers warehouse workers
delivery workers all these low-wage
service workers who
have always powered or not always but
have been powering our economy
suddenly recognizing that they are
essential
and that they are in many ways the
cultural heroes of the moment
that is an opening for us to realize
change and to see that the working class
in this country
is service-based it's multi-racial
it's a lot of women and people who've
been working in the shadows for far
too long and who deserve more than our
applause frankly
um and i think that reminding us
that this country it's majority working
class
and um and those are people who vote
and and you know that all of that
is and are the future of jobs in america
it's all on the ballot
um and i think the fact that we are in
such an
unprecedented crisis uh health crisis
an economic crisis and a crisis in our
democracy
just means that i think people will
start to make meaning
in a new way of the connections between
the three things
in a way that hopefully if organizers
like me and nicole do our jobs right
will actually create a whole new set of
possibilities in terms of policy
solutions
nicole how do you think that pandemic
has affected your work
so our our communities our our
indigenous communities are already hard
to reach communities and so
we've had to be really innovative in the
way that we
we reach people and so that means
being more uh present online
um putting dollars into ads so that
people can see
like with the the primary that happened
here in june some people
didn't realize that there was a primary
happening and so
um i think that we well i know that we
have to have
um that type of um
like unique reach to get to our
communities and so with some of the
things that we've done
in providing where other organizations
are providing relief
to to our communities with like um
like food food kits and such we
we partnered with those organizations to
put our information in
so that they can have a way to contact
us or see that we have like a landing
site
or landing landing page where they can
get information and just being
more accessible in more ways and that's
really helped us
in in the work that we're doing and also
um
being where our people are in fact like
on facebook i know facebook people give
facebook a lot of uh
gives people people think facebook has a
bad rep it's just like older people
but but um a lot of our indigenous
people are
are still using facebook and so we we
have identified the ways that we can
do outreach and try to be more creative
with those and also using traditional
means of media
newspaper ads texting mailers
and stuff like that and so it's just
been
it's been interesting to see how people
respond to
to the more traditional ways of
organizing
so we have a question from the audience
what would you say to people who have
said they're not going to vote at all in
this year's election
because they feel pessimistic about the
process and results
i i do you want to go agent no go ahead
nicole
i would say if you don't vote then the
the
whoever you i mean the
the election is decided then i mean like
you if you don't vote then you
the person that you were planning to
maybe vote for you know
loses another vote and so you need to be
there to have
and use your voice and especially with
with our our people and native people
you know we have we have that um
that uh that historical
um that history of not voting and so i
think it's it's time for us to make
voting a tradition and that's that's
something that that we
just need to do
i would say that cynicism is the enemy
of progress
that there's just no way you can have
expectations for yourself and your life
to improve or your
kids lives to improve if you um
if you sit it out you gotta you've gotta
you gotta do you got to make a play and
and really
if ever there was an election where that
was so clear
that um our country is in deep deep
crisis
and um we are in need
of leaders who reflect our values and
who will
solve for the tremendous
error shifting challenges of our time
um and um somebody had a really good
metaphor
about this of termites and you know you
might just think that your one little
vote doesn't matter
because it's like a little termite but
it's actually like termites in that
termites can take down the entire
foundation of a house
collectively and each of us
is one of those termites and each of us
needs to do our part
in order for that foundation not that
we're trying to bring down any
foundations but we are trying to
reinvent
and rebuild and um and so
i would say that that one it might feel
small but it's
actually fundamental
and two that we just can't be cynical
there's that's not a choice and in fact
that's a privilege
because um there are so many people who
can't afford
to not
care now
i think super majority had a study
recently about low propensity voters
why do people not vote and is there
something that could get them to
vote yeah so huge
many many reasons one is that most
employers don't give election day off
and so if you're a low-wage worker
working paycheck to paycheck which
two-thirds of all minimum wage workers
are women
and you know those are not jobs where
you can be like hey boss i'm gonna
i'm gonna be late you know
so that's one thing the other thing is
child care um figuring out especially if
you're going to have to be in a line for
four or five hours
i mean in 2018 i was at the polls in
georgia and there were people in line
for nine and ten hours
what are you going to do with your kids
so i just think there's a lot of
different reasons
why and and that's why we actually have
to just really
do the work and invest in people and
really talk to people
about why it's worth it even if it's
really hard
and and that it really it really matters
um and and and sometimes people need
more support
we should be setting up child care we
should be setting up
um you know ride shares because a lot of
people don't have transportation
right that kind of thing so um
and i think we're trying to shift the
frame from low propensity voters which
you know there's lots of words that are
kind of deficiency based
lens to to high potential voters
nicole what about people on the
reservations what are
what are some actual barriers that are
getting in their way
of voting so
the voter identification lie i mentioned
earlier is still
it's still active that law is still in
the books and so that is also
that's still a barrier people need to um
verify their address and find ways to
verify address and sometimes that's not
always
an accurate address that they're
assigned but um
more recently with the the primary that
we had
here in north dakota it was an all vote
by mail primary
we we believe that north dakota vote
that the
election should be be free and
accessible and fair um
and it wasn't i mean that that is not
happening here in north dakota
um in one case in my home reservation
um since it was an all
vote by mail primary you have to
find a way to obtain an absentee ballot
which you
the secretary of state remedied that by
sending out letters and telling them
they can download the ballot online
that's if you have internet access and
that's if you have the ability to
print a ballot and then
casting your ballot is also an issue
here in north dakota so if you wanted to
cast your absentee ballot
you either had to pay out of pocket you
know in some cases it could be up to two
dollars which is a lot of money for
people that are on a fixed income
pay out of pocket to pay the postage or
in my case in the case of my reservation
had to drive 40 miles one way in some of
the towns
to drop it in a free ballot box and so
that's some of the things that we've
identified and then being able to
are having the ability to track your
ballot you can track your ballot in
north dakota but
the secretary of state or the county
auditor that counts your ballot if it is
ruled as an invalid ballot you are not
notified
and so the state can cancel out your
ballot if you
cast it and there's something that you
know the signatures that don't
don't match and so there's a lot of um
complexities with with our electoral
system in north dakota that makes it
almost impossible for some people
in the very rural communities to vote
and there's so many little rules too you
might not know
when you're breaking the rule like if
your signature is a little bit off or
whatever
agenda people encounter that that you
work with
yeah yeah there's um
yes i mean and i think um in certain
states you're now seeing people get
dropped from the roles
um and uh people who've been registered
for a very long time suddenly purged
from the roles in places like georgia
and so i do think that it's really
important to just for everyone out there
to just double check that you're
registered now
and to just confirm that and um
and then to make sure that you're aware
of timelines around vote by mail
early voting things like that and um
super majority is a great resource for
that if you have questions
um about that process we're helping
people figure all that stuff out
um one thing that struck me about when i
was writing about the suffragists
was you know they had to convince men to
kind of share
power with them ultimately do you
feel like you have to convince people to
share
power with you i mean are we talking
about a
a fixed pie of power are we adding to
the pie by
including more people
in the political process
uh it's an interesting question i mean i
do
think that um the
a defining characteristic of our
existing political system
which was designed by and for men
is a culture of zero-sum
politics right where if you have power
it means i have less right and um
and i actually don't think that that's
how it works and i don't think that
women i don't want to stereotype or
women are not a monolith but from what i
see
in terms of how women's leadership works
it's less of a scarcity model and a
zero-sum model and more of an abundance
model
around how do we design for maximum
inclusion
right and um and so i think
that
yeah i guess i i would just say like
that's part of the problem
that culture of if you have more
it means i have less because this is a
country that is so abundant in so many
ways
and there's so much creativity and
innovation and it's just all directed
towards
more profits more convenience more
efficiency as opposed to greater equity
and opportunity
and so we just have to figure out how we
kind of re-prioritize here
and think about how to deploy all of
that creativity and innovation
towards helping us actually realize the
abundance in this country in such a way
that allows everyone to be
safe and whole and dignified in their
lives
and we are far from there and i know for
sure that a zero-sum power model is not
going to get us there
um what can people do
who you know are not domestic workers or
who are not
natives in north dakota to help
maybe not to share power but to build
the amount of power that's out there
do you want to take that yeah so i think
that
i mean i keep thinking about um
emergent strategy i don't know if you've
ever read the book but
she talks about how oak trees are on a
complex system underground and
hurricanes can pass through areas and
the oak trees will still be standing
it's because they go underground
and they connect their roots and that's
how they stay standing and we need to do
that we need to find
people where they're at and help them
[Music]
find their voice or help them get to the
polls or
you know we need to have those resources
available and
and like in in our communities you know
like with you what we were just talking
about power isn't shared
it's it's based on a deficit model you
know we
we need to go forward together and and
find people where they're at and give
them the resources that they need and so
like organizations like north dakota
native vote
that's what we do we we let the people
speak for themselves and
we give them that empowerment by giving
them the resources
and so um excuse me
so what other people can do is you know
talk to other people about the things
that
that are important to you if people you
know answer questions if you're
if you have the ability to answer
questions about people on the ballot and
stuff like that have those conversations
and let people know that
that these things are important that and
that their voice is important those are
things that
that we value as an organization as
having those conversations and building
that power
from from the roots upward
yeah yeah i agree with that and i would
just add that um
you know i don't think this is the kind
of time
in our history where you want to look
back and
wonder if you did enough you know
i think that um
yeah your kids and your grandkids are
going to ask you where were you what did
you do
you know and um we are in such such
deep crisis that it's an it's an all
hands on deck situation
and it doesn't mean you have to be like
me or monica and drive 10 million
bajillion miles around
i think there's a way to find your lane
based off of what feels authentic and
true to you
but is about action
and pro-action like pro-activity
towards whatever it means to you
to do more than you thought you could to
be a part of the solution and to help us
get out of this crisis
yeah i mean that's very powerful uh what
so imagine that
you all achieved everything you wanted
to achieve
everyone could vote with
little friction that there was
representation
of you know all sorts all the people
that make
america a beautiful country what
what would that look like to you what is
this
you know city on the hill what does it
look like
that would look like me not having a job
anymore
[Laughter]
no i'm kidding which would be great i
could go do something else
to be honest i i thought about this and
you know it would you know if we had
equal representation if we were
no longer underfunded under resourced
and
just no longer being subjugated
we would look like a suburb
our communities our communities would
have the things that we need
people would be at the table we would
have we would have equal
equal voice and we would also have the
ability to
to do make that change and have people
that are representing us that understand
poverty poverty that understand issues
in our communities
you know if we have those type of people
that were actual
actually doing it for the people like
some of the women that we do now have in
congress
the world would be so such a better
place
yeah if we we would have a totally
reflective democracy
and we would have bold
bold policy that would reset
our social safety net
our economy and
our democracy for this next era
in history and we would have
universal access to child care
and long-term care and paid leave and
health care
we'd have the fundamentals covered and
so that it would be about a question of
how we can contribute
how we can
[Music]
support and nurture the people that we
love
and um feel like you're making a
meaningful contribution
to this country without having to
struggle
so hard around the fundamentals and
there would be a lot more space for
creativity and dynamism and art
and music and um there would be a big
cultural renaissance that came out of
that where we would be
finding all these new ways of
experiencing joy
and learning from each other
that sounds pretty great so
well thank you so much nicole and i jen
it's
really been a wonderful conversation i
feel like i've learned
a lot and gotten a bit of a window
into the hard but essential work that
that you were doing and i hope that our
audience
did too is there any last things you'd
like to say or any
any places you'd like to point people to
um
in terms of your organizations i'm sure
you're all googleable
but um you can follow me on twitter
at igenpoo and i
co-host a podcast called sunstorm
which is all about how we continue to
shine through the storms
of our time and our politics and
it's co-hosted with alicia garza who's
one of the co-founders of black lives
matter
and um i just really hope everybody's
ready to do the work
let's go thank you
yeah you can follow north dakota native
vote on facebook instagram and twitter
or check us out on our webpage
ndnativevote.org great
well thank you so much and have a lovely
weekend
and we'll see bye
thank you